[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN MOTZENBECKER: Hey, I'm Dan.
It's a little experiment I
made called thing translator.
Lets you point your
camera at stuff
to hear how to say it
in a different language.
[CAMERA CLICK]
[NON-ENGLISH]
SPEAKER: Trophy
[CAMERA CLICK]
[NON-ENGLISH]
SPEAKER: Shoe.
[CAMERA CLICK]
[NON-ENGLISH]
SPEAKER: Electronic signage.
DAN MOTZENBECKER:
It's a little hack
using two of Google's
machine learning APIs,
Cloud Vision, and Translate.
You take a picture,
[CAMERA CLICK]
--send it to the
Cloud Vision API,
which returns a list of
labels for what it sees
and confidence
scores for each one.
I take the top one and send
it to the Translate API
to translate it.
And that's pretty much it.
It can do a bunch of
different languages.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
DAN MOTZENBECKER: It
works on your laptop,
too, since it's all
built for the web--
[CAMERA CLICK]
--and running in your browser.
[NON-ENGLISH]
SPEAKER: Pumpkin.
DAN MOTZENBECKER: You can
get the code for this demo,
and try it out at
g.co/aiexperiments.
[MUSIC PLAYING]